- Every show I pick out something awesome
from social media and share it with you.
Hopefully it makes you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
If you're a lover of football like myself
chances are you might
be in a fantasy league
while many people just play for fun.
For some groups,
the punishment for losing
can be pretty harsh.
Just look at what one
Chicago guy was subjected to.
- So sorry.
I'm going to be here a very long time.
I lost my fantasy football league
and my punishment is
I have to be here for 24 hours
and the only way I can get time taken off
is for every pancake I eat.
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- Yeah, I, It sounds absurd.
(laughs)
- It really does.
10 pancakes in 14 hours
in the diner later.
We have this very good
sport on the line right now.
Everybody say hi to Connor
watching on NBC Chicago at 3:00.
What's up Connor?
- Hi Kelly.
Thank you so much for having me.
- Oh my God, absolutely.
How were the pancakes?
(laughs)
- Oh man, you know what?
The first few delicious.
It's after pancake five or six.
They don't quite taste quite the same.
- Yeah. It's a little bit of a punishment.
Who came up with this punishment?
- So this fantasy group
is a group of buddies from high school
and some of us even went
to first grade together.
We go way back,
but now we live in five different states.
We're in four different time zones.
We're spread out
and fantasy football really
has kept our friendships alive.
It's been a beautiful thing for all of us,
but we do this punishment
to just keep each other
accountable and spice things up.
And we had heard the
lore of this punishment
but we'd never seen anyone do it.
You know, it was like the
Sasquatch of punishments
but we wanted to do it
and document it
so the world could see that it's done.
And so I was a huge advocate for it
because I didn't think I'd ever do it.
- Oh my gosh.
I love your fantasy lead team.
That's incredible.
And I love
that it's kept your friendships
alive for that long.
That's so cool.
Thank you Connor for sharing.
I'm liking your post right now.
I'm sorry to eat all those pancakes
but that's not all.
Our season long partner
pilot pen makers of G2
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
Want to honor truly unstoppable people
just like you Pancake man.
So they're going to be writing you
a cheque for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
- Oh My God.
- [Kelly] So Connor,
- That's incredible.
Thank you so much.
- Connor.
It's like a loss, but really a win.
Really a win at the end of the day.
Thank you so much.
Thank Connor.
Thank you to all our guests,
Tim Allen, Elizabeth Allen-Dick
Misty Copeland, Bonnie,
Dan and Lawrence Zarian.
And y'all have a great band.
If it's not, try harder .